GPT is a type of artificial intelligence
model developed by open AI it is a deep
learning model that is designed to
generate human-like text allowing it to
perform a wide range of language tasks
now I didn't write that that's how the
popular AI chatbot GPT chat describes
itself let's take a look at another
question that we've asked the bot what's
the capital of Germany that would seem
to be an easy one
and there it gets the answer right but
then it keeps going
all right
how about another one what's the best
classic rock band that's of course
subjective and as you see the bot also
says the same thing that's a very
subjective question
what about something more specific the
most interesting thing about eagles for
example
and now we see there's a very long list
of really interesting facts from
binocular vision to how they catch and
kill prey good enough it seems for your
next school project
well chat GPT isn't just a fun tool it's
popular as well in just a few days the
website has more than a million users
all all of them having created a login
and that's a bit of pressure for the
Googles of the world then there's the
bigger question is AI closer to being
able to do my job or even your job
I'm joined Now by Nicole putner she's
co-founder and CEO of mirantic's lab
that's a tech consulting firm here in
Berlin with a focus on AI Nicole it's
good to have you on the show
um this this chat bot seems to have very
normal sounding answers where is it
really good and where does it actually
struggle
um good morning and yeah I think it's
it's really solving an engineer's dream
of having natural in natural language as
an input and an output so you don't have
to have keywords or code but it's a very
seamless interaction I think that's also
a proof what you're just saying that a
lot of people have been using this
interface
um I think it is pushing us on with
regards to intelligence right what do we
see as intelligence as you said
generating text is that what we see as
intelligence or not
um and but I think on the on the counter
side the limitations are still factual
correctness for example so this model is
not able to solve the problem of factual
correctness that can quote also
completely false information yeah
there's one example we have here one
question that fools it is which mammals
lay the biggest eggs it gives the answer
of the elephant so obviously there's
some mistakes there I want to ask you a
new report in the New York Times says
that this uh this bot is setting off
alarm Bells at Google
um and other Tech firms that are maybe
been developing their own chat Bots but
haven't yet rolled them out should we
expect now to see a wave of these
generative AI is now really hitting the
the height Cycles so yes I expect that
there will be many startups but also
bigger tech companies rolling these out
I think what I personally find very
interesting because we're looking also
at industrial adoption so for deep
industry use cases right this will I
think take a lot longer because the data
that is you needed to generate
applications in that field is basically
behind walls right in the industrial
realm somewhere sitting in the company
so I think um yes we'll see more with
publicly available data like chat gbt
but in the industrial realm I think that
will take longer okay so this means that
businesses and workers shouldn't I
should say workers shouldn't be too
afraid yet businesses shouldn't get too
excited yet or is there an immediate uh
application that businesses can see in
this
I think um I think actually uh two
thoughts one is um Robotics and manual
labor have been I think a lot safer in
that regard because robotics is moving a
lot slower than we had anticipated so
there will be a lot of blue color
um jobs and Frontline worker jobs that
will be much harder to replace by any
such models however you were asking the
question about journalism right or
generating texts I think will be very
different right so I don't think
journalists will be obsolete because
factual correctness is important and um
and also generating truly original ideas
will remain important um in the future
but for sure there will be many
questions about summarizing texts like
writing minutes right that could be done
by this by this application Cole Butner
with tech consulting firm or Antics Labs
thank you very much
thank you